[Applaudissements]
je viens vous parler de vos données et
plus spécifiquement de vos données de
santé pourquoi parce que parce que
j'aime vos données j'adore vos données
et plus spécifiquement vos données de
santé nous avons créé il ya quatre ans
une société dont le but est de produire
ce que l'on appelle des thérapies
digital qu'est ce que c'est ce sont des
services d'accompagnement personnalisé
qui sont disponibles sur smartphone ou
sur le web qui vont aider nos
utilisateurs à prévenir les maladies
chroniques
plus encore ces services là vont aider
nos patients c'est à dire nos
utilisateurs qui malheureusement ont
déclaré une maladie chronique
alors quand je parle de maladies
chroniques je parle les maladies
cardiovasculaires je parle du diabète je
parle des cancers etc etc
donc nos services vont permettre à nos
patients qui ont déclaré une de ces
maladies chroniques de nous comprendre
leur maladie de mieux comprendre et de
mieux suivre leur traitement est
également de mieux savoir au quotidien
quelles sont les bonnes habitudes à
prendre pour mieux vivre et pour mieux
gérer la maladie
nous pensons pouvoir avoir un impact
énorme suivant l'organisation mondiale
de la santé les maladies chroniques sont
aujourd'hui la première cause de
mortalité dans le monde
devant l'ensemble des autres causes
réuni 36 millions de personnes meurent
chaque année à cause d'une maladie
chronique
ça c'est sur le plan humain et sur le
plan financier le diabète à lui seul
représente 20% des frais de santé aux
etats-unis 20% des frais de santé
et pourtant ce n'est pas une fatalité
parce que ces maladies chroniques ont
toutes un point commun c'est qu'elles
sont pour beaucoup dû à notre mode de
vie à nos habitudes du quotidien
toujours selon l'organisation mondiale
de la santé
en adaptant nos habitudes de vie en
minimisant les facteurs de risque
auxquels nous nous explosons chaque jour
à cause de nos comportements nous
pourrions éviter 75% des maladies
cardiovasculaires 75% et plus de 40% des
cancers cite un autre portait encore
faudrait-il que nous tous ayant une
bonne information sur ce qu'il convient
de faire en fonction de mon profil de
mon comportement de mon contexte où de
mon histoire génétique
c'est ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
nous faisons des services qui sont
extrêmement adapté extrêmement
personnalisé en fonction encore une fois
de votre profil de votre comportement et
de votre contexte mais aussi de vos
données médicales aussi de vos données
génétiques
plus nous aurons de données vous
concernant plus nous serons capables de
mieux vous accompagner et vous aider à
mieux vivre et peut-être même c'est
ambitieux mais de vous sauver la vie
alors c'est une noble cause le sujet sur
cette cause c'est que je vois déjà
certains dans la salle parlé et je suis
persuadé qu'il ya au moins un tiers de
la salle voire la moitié voire peut-être
les trois quarts de la salle je peux
dire toute la salle sinon je il faut que
je parte mais qui est en train de se
dire mais qu'est ce qu'il raconte
encore un qui parle de mes données de
santé qui va prendre mes données de
santé qui va les y tue les utiliser je
ne sais pas où ces données vont aller je
vais perdre le contrôle de mes données
de santé et il y à fort à parier que on
va utiliser ses données de santé contre
moi à mon insu alors je peux pas vous en
vouloir parce qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas un seul article de presse qui ne
parle des données de santé en finissant
sur une mise en garde sur le principe de
attention où vous mettez vos données de
santé dont j'ai gardé vos données de
santé pour vous il n'ya pas un seul
reportage à la télé qu'ils finissent sur
une ouverture encore plus angoissantes
sur un prétendu monde aurélien où nous
serions rentrés à votre insu où tout le
monde nous veut du mal et tout le monde
nous veut du mal par rapport à nos
données et spécifiquement nos données de
santé alors je suis pas là pour être
naïf je suis pas là non plus pour être
angélique jeu
les données de santé ont un tel
potentiel que j'aimerais juste recadrer
le débat et partager avec vous quelques
pensées déjà recadré le débat parce que
en france il ne peut pas y avoir de
mésusage de vos données de santé
la loi est très précise sur ce point il
ya des organismes type la cnil qui
veille au grain qui veille plutôt bien
aux grains ne vous inquiétez pas vous
êtes protégé il y à une protection
juridique est très importante au niveau
de vos données de santé et cette
protection juridique va être encore
renforcé en mai prochain lors de
l'entrée en vigueur de nouveaux
règlements général de protection des
données
peut-être en avez vous entendu parler
vous avez sans doute beaucoup en
entendre parler dans les prochains mois
ce nouveau règlement général de
protection des données
introduit énormément de protection par
rapport à vos données de santé est en
plus très concrètement il donnait santé
aujourd'hui doit être cryptées peut être
chiffrée
ce qui veut dire que si ce n'est pas
votre passé si ce n'est pas votre
médecin ou si ce n'est vous personne
d'autre ne peut arriver à des chiffres
et autres données de santé c'est un
point important parce qu'aujourd'hui
vous pouvez vous dire bon eh bah du coup
vous pouvez avoir confiance en la loi
vous pouvez avoir confiance dans les
organismes régulateurs pour partager vos
données de santé alors d'enlever
tranquille citoyens tout va bien et
partager vos données de santé je veux
juste revenir sur un point que je viens
d'énoncer pas sur la sécurité de vos
données
parce que là la sécurité de vos données
la protection de données elle est là
mais il est toujours intéressant de
regarder le débat de l'autre côté j'ai
toujours dit depuis le début du toc
j'ai toujours parlé de vos données de
santé la question est et vous sûr que ce
sont vos données de santé là j'ai perdu
le dernier quart de la salle
mais la question n'est pas si n'est pas
si bête
et parce que la réponse n'est pas si
simple premiers éléments de réponse
une donnée en tant que telle n'a pas de
propriété c'est un fait c'est un fait
juridique une donnée en tant que telle
n'a pas de propriété passons vous allez
me dire c'est un argument juridique on
les évacue tout de suite on ira beaucoup
mieux avec ça de toutes façons m'as
donné m'appartient est à moi donc elle
est à ce point personnel qu'elle
n'appartient forcément oui mais non
autre exemple aujourd'hui
imaginons qu'une donnée finalement une
donnée de santé imaginons là comme un
accessoire d'un de vos organes après
tout votre rythme cardiaque ou votre
tension n'est qu'un accessoire de votre
coeur votre taux de glycémie ne peut
être qu'un accessoire de votre pancréas
c'est directement issue de cet organe en
suivant ce principe si l'on se réfère
alors je crois que c'est l'article 16 du
code civil
cet article 16 met en avant le principe
d'indisponibilité du corps ce qui veut
dire que concrètement dans le code civil
peut-être ne le saviez vous pas mais
votre corps ne vous appartient pas au
sens où il vous est impossible de le
vendre
donc si dans le code civil votre corps
ne vous appartient pas si on considère
qu'une de données de santé est un
accessoire d'un de vos organes de fait
une donnée ne vous appartient pas vous
allez me dire oui enfin bon peu importe
ce sont encore des inepties juridique
passons évacuant les la donner elle est
sur moi j'en fais ce que je veux donc à
peu près à priori tout va bien vous en
êtes vous aussi sur jeu je me réfère à
ce que dit un expert de ces questions
l'avocat maître pierre desmarais qui
expert de ces questions là et lui parle
de paternalisme juridique parce
qu'aujourd'hui les législateurs français
ou européen considère que nous ne sommes
pas assez autonome sur ces questions là
est aujourd'hui très concrètement nous
sommes privés de notre libre arbitre
quant au sujet des données de santé
notamment je prends un exemple
le séquençage du génome donc le
séquençage du génome
c'est une excellente nouvelle
parce que le séquençage du génome
finalement c'est le nec plus ultra de
vos données de santé c'est un une
immense montagne de données vous
concernant
bonne nouvelle le séquençage du génome
ya 15 ans coûté 3 milliards $ environ
et maintenant vous pouvez le trouver sur
internet auprès de start up américaine à
quelques centaines d'euros
c'est une excellente nouvelle parce que
vous allez avoir accès directement un
immense volume de données vous
concernant
imaginez ce que vous allez pouvoir en
faire avec vous allez pouvoir utiliser
toutes ces données là pour les corréler
avec les données de personnes qui ont le
même profil que vous vous allez pouvoir
utiliser ces données pour les corréler
avec celles des membres de votre famille
vous allez pouvoir les confronter à vos
données de profils de vous donner de
comportement vos données de contexte et
vous allez pouvoir
à coup sûr vous dire est en tout cas
découvrir le potentiel de risque que
vous avez déclenché une maladie
chronique
je fais un peu people c'est ce qu'a fait
madame angélina jolie lorsqu'elle à
séquencer son génome elle a découvert
qu'elle souffrait d'une récession d'un
certain gène qui lui prédisaient
malheureusement pour elle un taux très
élevé de d'avoir un cancer du sein dans
les prochaines années et l'a choisi la
double mastectomie en prévention
c'est une très bonne utilisation des
données de santé on peut aller encore
même plus loin
imaginez la richesse des données de
votre génome imaginez la richesse des
données de santé qui vous entourent de
votre comportement de votre profil
encore une fois imaginez la richesse
pour vous de ces données par rapport à
votre santé vous pourriez savoir quels
sont vos risques et vous pouvez savoir
quelles sont vos hypothèses de
déclencher un cancer ou une maladie
cardiovasculaire dans quelques années et
ainsi adapter votre comportement
c'est génial mais c'est tout à fait
interdite en france
c'est tout à fait illégal ces mêmes
pénalement répréhensible vous ne pouvez
pas faire c'est quand c'est votre génome
en france pour les raisons de
paternalisme juridique on a évoqué plus
plus plus plus en amont je parle de ça
alors bien sûr l'exemple est traité de
manière un peu rapide un peu simpliste
le séquençage du génome à but
thérapeutique existe en france dans des
cas très précis mais le
le point me semblait extrêmement
intéressant d'aborder parce que ça met
le question pour moi sur la vraie
question par rapport à ce débat à ce
débat sur les données de santé
aujourd'hui le débat sur les données de
santé est totalement polluée par des
inepties un peu paranoïaque qui est de
se dire oh mon dieu mon employeur va
avoir accès à mes données va me
licencier parce que je fume un peu trop
où mon dieu ma mutuelle va avoir accès à
mes données et du coup parce que j'ai
pas les bons comportements parce que je
ne marche pas assez parce que je fume
parce que je bois un peu trop d'alcool
va monter automatiquement le montant de
sa prime mais on en est très loin parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est illégal est
aujourd'hui sans que ces acteurs là vous
le voulez vous le demande c'est tout à
fait impossible pour eux d'utiliser ces
données pour ce cadre là le gros
problème de ça c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
ya une telle paranoïa sur le marché
autour de ses données de santé que tout
le monde se referment et que tout le
monde est tétanisé à l'idée de partager
ses données de santé et qu'on passe à
côté du potentiel de ces données santé
et c'est le but de ce taux que ces deux
peut-être modestement vous ouvrir
l'esprit en se disant en vous disant
soyez rassurés parce que la loi la cnil
veille sur vous quant à une mauvaise
utilisation possible par des tiers de
vos données de santé mais pour autant
battez vous pour libérer vos données de
santé ayez confiance dans vos données de
santé ayez confiance dans leur potentiel
pour vous aider à mieux vivre et pour
vous aider à vous sauver la vie
ayez confiance dans vos données de santé
parce que c'est elle qui demain vont
constituer le socle de votre relation
avec votre médecin
il est vraiment temps aujourd'hui de
laisser vos données de santé vous sauver
la vie et celle des autres
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci paul louis